let's jump into this next one we have
this tweet from Mario knul this is one
of the more shocking so I will just say
this is not for the Fain of heart and uh
you know just be mindful we we'll try to
keep the language somewhat delicate for
those who are listening with their
families this is serious news stuff but
um I hope you're prepared to to uh hear
this Alan dtz is accused of having uh um
forcing adult relations on a minor Noel
tweets Epstein forced Miner to have
let's just say adult relations with
Harvard Law Professor Alan dtz I'm going
to add according to testimony from the
document this does not mean it's
absolutely
true Jane Doe number three is a minor
who was forced to have adult let's just
call adult contact with people on behalf
of Epstein here's the document reads one
such powerful individual that Epstein
forced then minor Jane Doe to have
relations with was former Harvard Law
Professor Alan dtz a close friend of
Epstein and well no criminal defense
attorney Epstein required Jano number
three to have relations with dtz on
numerous occasions while she was a minor
not only in Florida but also on private
planes in New York New Mexico and the US
Virgin Islands in addition to being a
participant in the abuse of Jan number3
and other minors dwood was an eyewitness
to the sexual abuse of many other minors
by Epstein and several of Epstein's
co-conspirators dershwitz would later
play a significant role in negotiating
the NPA on behalf of Epstein on
Epstein's behalf indeed dwoods helped to
negotiate and agreement that provided
immunity from federal prosecution in the
southern district of Florida not only to
Epstein but also to any potential
co-conspirators of Epstein NPA at 5 it
says thus dtz helped negotiate an
agreement with a provision that provided
protection for himself against criminal
prosecution in Florida for abusing janeo
number three because his broad immunity
would have been controversial if
disclosed dtz along with other members
of Epstein's defense team and the
Government tried to keep the immunity
Provisions secret from all of Epstein's
victims and the general public even even
though such secrecy violated the crime
victim's Rights
Act yo do there's a lot of documents
that got released this is absolutely uh
shocking to see now we we we just had
the story today from the New York Post
Alan dershwitz says quote a lot of
people hung out with Epstein claims
document dump will exonerate him yeah
well that did not go as planned for him
my question then would be for Mario nul
which what which document is sighting on
this
one so I I would like I think I want to
I want to make sure we can get that one
pulled up properly cuz I want to I want
to I'm I try to be very very careful
here right uh I I I I don't see Mario
knul is just making something up posting
something like this this is a document
he clearly you know uh uh found screen
grab but he's got to you got to post the
sources on this one man because this is
a very very very serious accusation
against dtz it's also specific it's
detailed
so I think it's hard to uh uh to imagine
what else will come out but I feel like
it's just going to get worse and worse
worse like is this the first one that we
found it's not been released why do you
mean what do you mean it's hard to
imagine cuz I like do you want your
brain to be able to imagine the worst
things that could happen to people like
well I mean that's a special talent just
hope don't have pH if you can imagine
terrible tortures I don't want to know
it's one thing to say like I don't want
to imagine it fine like that's fine but
I don't understand why why it's hard to
imagine these these people there's not
really a li to the Deviant like I don't
think that there's like whatever like
the grossest things you can come up to
come up with maybe they're not SN maybe
they wouldn't do perform snuff films but
everything else honestly I that would
not surprise me I wouldn't be completely
shocked either you know but but the it's
like to think that there that there's
any any limit to the these people are
like they're literally the the most
powerful people in the world there's no
limit to what they'll do what I don't
understand is how like okay so you
become a politician you be you get a
position of power MH what is the the
weird segue that you're like oh there's
this guy Epstein you know he hooks you
up with little like what is like who's
going to even try and have that
conversation you know what the rumor is
about Epstein right that he's that he
was some kind of asset for the for
intelligence uh for the for CIA possibly
for mad but the rumor was that he would
put people in positions of power in
compromising positions and get uh
information on him so that way he could
in infuence them on behalf of you know
on behalf of government so essentially
what he does is he just you know is
offering whatever he wants so like
someone like can hold it against you
yeah I have a feeling Donald Trump like
wants like wants someone to like he
wants to call someone Mommy because he's
like in charge all the time and he's
like a power guy so that's why he's he's
not after that's why it seem or that's
my
imagination R it
wasbe because Stormy Daniels wasn't
Young when he was alleged to have hooked
up with her she was she would have been
considered like a a cougar age so also
maybe he's just not a pedophile you know
sayit most disturbing which is that like
yes there are some of these girls who
are like 17 right so you get like creepy
arguments that they're you know they
look older or whatever else like it's
all gross and weird I think with Trump
the fact that we regularly see in this
that he was like haha I'm not taking
part in this shows a level of uh moral
fortitude that
obviously obviously people thatal for no
I think so I think maybe not entirely
I'm not saying he's perfect but in this
case you're asking how do people stumble
into this and I think there's a level
where people have no values and that
they think ultimately they deserve to do
whatever they want I think you're giving
him too much credit I think that this
just happens to not be his particular
flavor of deviant sure fine but that
doesn't mean that he's a good dude who
wouldn't do something gross and deviant
the fact that the establishment went
after him the way they did when he ran
for president implies to me that he
wouldn't be a part of this weird yeah so
just
we got the new we got the news team
currently working on it it looks like
what marul posted is from Exhibit C and
uh yeah it says what it says so um I'm
not exactly sure this is it says filed
010324 page one it's a CV Joiner motion
uh it looks like the this document is
related to Jane do one and Jane do 2 V
the United States in which they make
reference to Alan dtz and the the the
abuse of these minors it may be that
this actual Court filing was used as
evidence in in the JRA case meaning
Virginia jefra says like their lawyers
are like look at these documents that
were previously in in uh uh court of law
there's a lot there's a lot here a lot
of stuff to go through yeah I mean uh in
uh looks like exhibit 5 there's uh one
witness who says she was Rec uh the
question and what did you understand her
story to be did she tell you I don't
know it's referring to it could could be
you fre I'm not sure answer that she was
recruited to give massages sexual
massages and have sex with people such
as dtz and Andrew but I know I knew none
of that at the time that's prince
Andrew
yo holy crap
dude um what worries me about all this
stuff coming out is that you know you
back a rabbit cute little thing huh cute
little thing you see it outside it runs
away that you back it into a Corner that
thing will bite you mhm these people
ain't rabbits these are psychotic wolves
that's unfair these are demons yeah
they're demons these are deranged
psychotic individuals and they are
backed into a corner so when you see
this let me show you this Mario no's
tweet he posts this uh he posts this uh
an additional I believe this from
Exhibit C and it says J number three was
forced to have sexual relations with
this Prince when she was a minor in
three separate geographical locations
London New York and an Epstein's Private
Island wow it goes on to
say another person in Epstein's Inner
Circle of Friends is Jean Luke Brunell
Epstein sexually trafficked J number
three to Jean Luke Brunell many times
Brunell was another one of Epstein's
closest friends and a regular traveling
companion from CNN February 21st 2022
French modeling agent Jean Luke Brunell
found dead in prison cell
I wonder what that means found alone and
hanged with bed sheets in his jail cell
at the Sant prison in the French Capital
around 130 a.m. shot in the back of his
head you do not say you got to be
kidding me suicide with bullet to the
back of the head there is that story of
that journalist remember that one what's
his name uh he was uh he was
investigating the CIA oh that they said
got robbed and no no no no they said he
killed himself but he had two gunshots
to the Head yeah mhm and they're like
look sometimes you survive he's just
committed there's a there's a
termination over there there is a quote
the Pitzer prize is not the highest
award in journalism being assassinated
by the CIA is yeah that's crazy thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at
timcast.net
I